[Música]
el fentanilo es el principal responsable
de las muertes por sobredosis en Estados
Unidos y se ha convertido en una amenaza
a la salud pública es un opiaceo
sintético que se encuentra en forma de
polvo pastillas inyección Y hasta en
gotas comenzó a utilizarse en los 90
para aliviar los dolores crónicos y poco
a poco ha entrado en el mercado ilegal
el riesgo es que es 50 veces más potente
que la heroína y 100 veces más que la
morfina la DEA explica que sólo dos
miligramos de fentanilo que es lo que
cabe más o menos en la punta de un lápiz
pueden matar a una persona y no solo es
más letal sino que además es más barato
y más difícil de detectar por eso desde
hace unos años Los Traficantes
comenzaron a mezclarlo con cocaína
heroína y metanfetaminas y también NBA
por lo que muchos llegan a consumirlo
sin siquiera saberlo el resultado es que
en 2021 casi 107 mil personas murieron
de sobredosis en Estados Unidos una
cifra nunca antes vista y que duplica la
del 2015 cuando se disparó el consumo de
fentanilo en el país las estadísticas de
los centros para el control y prevención
de enfermedades muestran además que este
opiáceo sintético es el mayor causante
de aquellas muertes por sobredosis pues
provocó cerca de tres cuartas partes de
los fallecimientos en 2021 muy por
encima de las metanfetaminas la cocaína
la heroína entre otros
A qué se debe este drástico repunte del
consumo de fentanilo en Estados Unidos
Quiénes están detrás de la producción y
cómo estaba afectando la salud de miles
de personas para responder a estas
preguntas en el debate nos acompaña
desde Albuquerque Michael Vigil ex jefe
de operaciones internacionales de la DEA
y en Ciudad de México está Miguel Ángel
Vega periodista de investigación y autor
de El fixer un libro que relata las
dificultades de entrar a las cocinas de
drogas y estar en medio de jefes de
carteles y también de agentes federales
antes de comenzar a hablar con ellos les
recuerdo a nuestros televidentes que
también hacen parte de nuestro programa
pueden dejar todos sus comentarios y
preguntas en las redes sociales estamos
como arroba franz24 raya al piso es la
etiqueta es numeral el debate f-24 y a
mí me encuentran como arroba María
claguirre no olviden también que todos
los contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast Spotify
deezer TuneIn quiero comenzar entonces
dándole la bienvenida de nuevo a
nuestros invitados y concretamente a
Michael Vigil Michael Gracias por estar
con nosotros y empecemos por hablar a
qué se debe este repunte del consumo de
fentanilo en Estados Unidos
esto se trata de una epidemia que se
inició
así por compañías farmacéuticas por
ejemplo como
que comenzaron a distribuir a drogas
sintéticas aquí en los Estados Unidos
entonces la epidemia cambió en 2010
aproximadamente cuando se volteó y la
gente aquí en los Estados Unidos comenzó
a consumir heroína Y entonces tres años
después 2013 entonces comenzaron a
consumir fentanilo y ahora es un crisis
supremamente grave aquí en los Estados
Unidos el año pasado se incautó
suficiente contenido para matar a toda
la población aquí en los Estados Unidos
y entonces está entrando por tonelada
desde México aquí a los Estados Unidos y
los carteles principales son el
cartel de Jalisco Nueva Generación ellos
ahora no se están enfocando tanto
en drogas así basadas en plantas y no
drogas sintéticas como contenido y
metanfetamina usted menciona
precisamente las Las capturas que hizo
la DEA o la incautación mejor que hizo
la DEA en 2022 concretamente la cifra es
50,6 millones de píldoras falsas de
fentanilo es decir que no venían de los
mercados legales y tampoco eran
prescritas por un médico y 4.500 kilos
de polvo de fenta Nilo el cálculo de la
DEA Es que esto equivale a 379 millones
de dosis por lo que usted dice que
podrían matar básicamente a todos los
estadounidenses Pues el país tiene una
población de alrededor de 330 millones
de personas Miguel Ángel le quiero dar
la bienvenida a usted cómo entender el
impacto de esta cantidad de fentanilos
circulando en Estados Unidos y más la
que no se incautó
Bueno evidentemente hay una
sobreproducción de fentanilo en
en entre los carteles mexicanos a Mike
mencionaba por ejemplo al grupo de
Sinaloa y al cartel de Jalisco y bueno
Esto surgió precisamente a partir de
esta epidemia porque en Estados Unidos
en los 90s y principios de este Milenio
empezaron a recetar a Pain Killers
estos antídotos para calmar el dolor en
personas que tienen enfermedades
crónicas Y estos estos pen Killers
tenían a un cierto grado de fentanilo Y
eso provocó una epidemia en entre las
personas que padecían alguna enfermedad
Crónica o otro tipo de enfermedades
terminantes y bueno cuando la el Estados
Unidos se da cuenta de esta epidemia
trata de Cancelar de
que se prescriban estas esos
medicamentos pero ya era muy tarde ya
había a cientos de miles de adictos y
esos adictos cuando ya no se no pueden
conseguir esta esta droga en los
pentiles pues empezaron a buscar otros
medios y el medio fue fue la heroína fue
el mercado negro de pedazos sintéticos y
aquí es donde llega la producción de
fentanilos carteles de la drogas se dan
cuenta de que ahí hay un mercado muy
importante de donde pueden sacar a
grandes cantidades millonarias de dinero
y empiezan a producir pastillas m-30
empiezan a mezclar a producir fentanilo
y mezclarlo con otras drogas como las
metanfetaminas la cocaína a la heroína
etcétera entonces se da una una crisis
terrible que hasta 2015 es cuando
Estados Unidos finalmente se da cuenta
de la magnitud del problema y antes de
hablar analizar lo que ha pasado desde
el 2015 hasta ahora le quiero preguntar
a Michael porque lo que dice Miguel
Ángel él se refiere a las dos olas
previas al fentanilo que fueron una la
de los medicamentos para calmar el dolor
como la oxicodona entre los 90 y el 2000
y luego esto se frena ya la medicación
para y las farmacéuticas paran de
proveer tantos medicamentos contra el
dolor y es Entonces cuando las personas
van que ya tienen la adicción van hacia
la heroína y finalmente esto termina en
el fentanilo teniendo en cuenta esto hay
alguna responsabilidad en las raíces de
la sobreproducción farmacéutica y la
sobre medicación
totalmente porque hay muchas compañías
aquí en los Estados Unidos compañías que
producen estas drogas Entonces ellos así
para aumentar sus ganancias no les
importaba de la salud de los
norteamericanos Entonces esto como dice
Miguel eso comenzó la ola la primera ola
eran las compañías farmacéuticas y no de
ahí
nos drogadictos no podían pagar por esas
drogas farmacéuticas entonces
comenzaron a utilizar heroína que era
más barata y más fácil para conseguir
consumir y luego de ahí se voltearon y
comenzaron a consumir
ventanilos yo tuve que hacer una
entrevista
hace unos cuantos años pasado en
televisión de la China y entonces Yo
comencé a buscar en el internet
si podía comprar yo un kilo de fentanilo
en cinco minutos
localicé una compañía en Beijing y
Estaban vendiendo un kilo puro de
fentanilo por poquito más de nueve mil
dólares Si yo fuera narcotraficante
fuera comprado ese kilo de fentanilo no
hubiera tenido una ganancia de dos o
tres millones de dólares
y usted Menciona un punto que es clave
en toda esta discusión o bueno dos
primero china que es el principal
productor de fentanilo y a diferencia de
lo que están haciendo los carteles
mexicanos el fentanilo de China tiene
una pureza de cerca del 90 por ciento
como incide china en lo que está pasando
en Estados Unidos y dos el precio sobre
todo comparando con otras drogas como la
cocaína o la heroína qué tan barato es
el fentanilo
michaeles químicos tienen principalmente
de China que es altp o npp y entran por
los puertos marítimos por ejemplo Lázaro
Cárdenas en Michoacán también por
Manzanillo con lima y Veracruz en
cantidades grandes y entran a manos de
los carteles y es muy fácil para para
cometer esos químicos precursores a
pentánino mucha gente dice Ah pues
tienen la super laboratorios no son
súper laboratorios son pilas de metal y
usan hasta una pala para mezclar los
químicos Entonces les cuesta unos
centavos para producir una pastilla de
fentanilo y no aquí en los Estados
Unidos se puede vender desde 100 dólares
a 30 dólares Ahora sí quiero ir con
usted Miguel Ángel porque precisamente
el libro que usted escribió cuenta en
parte esta realidad y la dificultad de
los periodistas para entrar a estos
lugares donde se produce el fentanilo
conoce usted esta realidad y es tan
fácil producir fentanilo con los
químicos que están entrando a México
desde china como lo dice Michael
Sí sí es sumamente fácil porque son
laboratorios como bien dice Mike son
locales muy rudimentarios que están
muchas veces en medio de las montañas en
zonas muy inhóspitas donde no hay flujo
de personas y donde para los militares o
la Marina es muy difícil accesar y son
los autores que están ocultos y son
básicamente como como decía Michael
efectivamente Son son tinas que que
ellos baten a veces con palas a veces
con palos a veces con lo que tienen otra
vez están un poco más sofisticados y
tienen una especie de taladros y que le
conectan una una cuchara hasta abajo con
una extensión y y así es como baten las
cosas pero sí son lugares muy
rudimentarios son muy fáciles de hacer
pero aquí la la cuestión es que es muy
las ni las autoridades mexicanas ni las
de Estados Unidos han encontrado una
forma de detener el tráfico de el
presente de México López Obrador dice
que aquí no se no se hace a fentanilo
aquí se produce muchísimo fentanilo
porque a mí me ha tocado hacer
investigaciones de campo en donde he
estado en cocinas de de heroína cocinas
de fentanilo y me he dado cuenta de que
sí lo están produciendo y lo están
produciendo en cantidades industriales y
muchas y y posteriormente lo pueden
enviar de muchas maneras a Estados
Unidos que es el mercado final para para
esta droga y puede ser puede ser enviado
en polvo o puede ser enviado en
pastillas m30 Porque una vez que está el
fentanilo puro lo mezclan con otras
sustancias en en otro tipo de locaciones
para hacer las pastillas m-30 y bueno
Esto está ocurriendo hay una aquí en
en México particularmente en el Estado
de Sinaloa hay una sobreproducción de
pastillas
y las y son muy fáciles de producir son
muy fáciles de enviar porque son el
fentanilo es más difícil de detectar que
el resto de las drogas y eso ha hecho
que que la epidemia la crisis para el
consumo de fentanilo en Estados Unidos
siga a la alza y esté mucha gente esté
muriendo por sobredosis y en esta muerte
de sobredosis una de las mayores
responsables es precisamente Cómo se
produce ese fentanilo la historia
original y que publica por ejemplo el
diario el País de España es que fue el
químico Ricardo Valdez Torres apodado el
cerebro el que supuestamente le dijo al
chapo necesitamos dedicarnos al
fentanilo y le dijeron al chapo sin
embargo esto se tiene que diluir y que
los carteles mexicanos no lo han hecho o
no lo han sabido hacer usted que ha
conocido en terreno esto qué tan cierto
es
bueno la realidad de las cosas es que
los cocineros y los traficantes de droga
que hay en México ellos mandan el
fentanilo puro y ya es una cuestión de
los vendedores en las calles de los
Estados Unidos diluirlo Entonces ellos
ellos de un kilo de fentanilo pueden lo
cortan con otras sustancias y llegan a
hacer hasta diez kilos eso es decir que
si un kilo le van a sacar Por decirlo
unos 40 mil dólares en la costa este
Estados Unidos al final del día terminan
sacándole 10 kilos porque lo cortan y y
bueno cuando una vez que está en las
calles si El vendedor de droga el dealer
finalmente no lo corta Pues podría matar
a todos los usuarios porque es una droga
muy potente que como como dicen los
analistas a tres granos de fentanilo
podrían matar por sobredosis a una
persona que lo usa mi eso es lo que
estamos viendo en Estados Unidos un
fentanilo que no están cortando y que es
fácilmente encontrable como una
sobredosis
Estados Unidos no lo van a ocultar
porque ya viene en pastillas aparte de
eso son pastillas falsas nos drogaditos
no saben ellos piensan que como dice
Miguel son m30 que es como oxicodono
Entonces no saben que están utilizando
y cuando una persona consume drogas
ilegales no hay control de calidad y los
narcotraficantes no les importa muchas
veces a mí me preguntan Me están matando
a todos sus clientes están matandolos a
todos porque aquí en los Estados Unidos
nacen como a tres millones de personas
anualmente
Entonces es esa gente que se va a
reemplazando y va comprando drogas
Entonces nosotros lo que tenemos que
hacer aquí en los Estados Unidos es
mejorar la situación donde reducimos el
consumo porque si no Entonces vamos a
tener problemas anteriormente
los carteles se enfocaban en las
ciudades grandes las zonas
metropolitanas ahora el cartel de
Jalisco Nueva Generación se está
enfocando en zonas Rurales porque son
mercados nuevos para ellos Entonces eso
también está causando
muchas muertes de sobredosis y ese punto
que usted menciona ha sido vital porque
el fentanilo está siendo consumido por
todas las clases socioeconómicas Esto no
es y no está siendo una droga
simplemente de ricos o de personas que
viven en lugares más pobres No esto es
una droga generalizada pero quiero
preguntarle algo a Miguel Ángel porque
usted dice México está produciendo
cantidades industriales de fentanilo
algo que está negando el gobierno y el
presidente de Andrés Manuel López
Obrador y que ha sido precisamente una
batalla y una atención bastante álgida
entre Estados Unidos y México y
recientemente amlo Incluso le pidió a
China que colaborara para cortar el
tráfico de fentanilo desde ese país Cómo
es la atención geopolítica entre Estados
Unidos y México por el fentanilo y usted
cree que sea posible o no que los
carteles de narcotráfico sean declarados
como terroristas lo que le permitiría a
Estados Unidos combatirlos Más allá de
sus fronteras
bueno los anuncios recientes que ha
hecho el gobierno de Estados Unidos en
contra de los carteles mexicanos
particularmente lo que es el cartel
Sinaloa han puesto en alerta mucho a los
grupos criminales de aquí de de en
México particularmente lo que es el
grupo que opera en Sinaloa y bueno ellos
ellos sí tienen una gran responsabilidad
respecto a lo que está ocurriendo porque
no hay ningún tipo de
de control de calidad no hay ningún tipo
de culpa no hay nada ellos solamente
están empeñados en hacer dinero y el
problema aquí el otro problema que yo
veo es que los principales consumidores
de droga están en Estados Unidos yo creo
que Estados Unidos tiene que a arreglar
de alguna manera ese problema porque las
estrategias contra las drogas no han
funcionado
nunca han funcionado nunca hasta el
momento no ha ocurrido y yo creo eso se
debe a que el tema de las drogas no es
un problema propiamente de seguridad
pública sino que es un problema de salud
pública y mientras haya haya quien
consuma quién compre quién pague por
esas drogas va a ver quién quién las
venda porque las ganancias que los
carteles de la droga obtienen de del
tráfico y de la venta de estos drogas
sintéticas Son son millones de dólares
entonces nadie le va a decir que no a
ese a ese ingreso Y Bueno yo pienso que
es algo que que tiene que detenerse de
alguna manera Aunque yo para ser
sinceros yo no veo que esto se vaya a
detener en un corto ni mediano plazo con
la misma estrategia contra las drogas
que los gobiernos de México Estados
Unidos están utilizando y de hecho como
lo veíamos en los gráficos del inicio se
está es disparando por el contrario
Michael Le quiero preguntar Usted cree
que Estados Unidos debería combatir el
fentanilo como una alarma de salud
pública y no solo como seguridad pública
y sobre todo cuéntenos un poco dentro
del país Cuál es esta atención sobre
todo entre los republicanos que están
pasando la cuenta de cobro a los
demócratas por el repunte del fentanilo
hay muchos problemas con los
republicanos que no tienen ninguna
táctica para terminar con esta problema
de ventanilo y la única cosa que se
pasan haciendo es atacando a los
democratas Entonces nosotros necesitamos
una estrategia una estrategia que
va a atacar el consumo necesitamos de
educar a nuestra juventud y aparte de
eso a tratarlo como si fuera una
problema de salud también te quiero
decir que mucha gente nos republicanos
dicen Ah queremos invadir a México hay
el ejército y nunca lo van a hacer
porque es teatro político pero como
tienes conocimiento las palabras tienen
impacto Y eso ha causado que las
relaciones en el combate de este
problema sean dañado totalmente y no lo
republicanos dicen Ah pues hay que
Designar a los carteles así como grupos
terroristas y eso no va a funcionar
Porque la única cosa que hace es que los
Estados Unidos puede congelar las
cuentas de esos grupos designados como
terroristas nada más aquí en los Estados
Unidos no al exterior puede sancionar al
ciudadanos americanos si tienen Trato
con empresas de estos grupos y lo
tercero tratan de prevenir que estas
personas entren a los Estados Unidos es
todo lo que hace entonces para mí algo
simbólico nada más y usted menciona que
es importante
abordar una estrategia que ataque el
consumo de fentanilo usted cree que esto
está pasando en Estados Unidos
tiene una estrategia Pero siempre los
republicanos se oponen pero yo creo que
ahora se está mejorando porque es una
estrategia que va incorporando por
ejemplo en las agencias de policía
federales estatales municipales locales
y aparte de eso el tratamiento de los
drogadictos y luego para y no también
esfuerzos para reducir el consumo Pero
como dice Miguel Esto va a ser de largo
plazo no va a suceder un día al otro
Miguel y le quiero preguntar a usted
cómo se vive esta realidad del otro lado
de la frontera si bien los mexicanos en
México el consumo de fentanilo no es
alto y como usted bien lo decía son los
estadounidenses los que más lo están
consumiendo Cómo está afectando la
producción de fentanilo sobre todo la
seguridad en México
Bueno es muy curioso porque aquí en
México y particularmente yo me he
enterado que en la ciudad en ciudades
como Culiacán está prohibido la venta de
fentanilo por los efectos que causa en
donde una persona Una vez que se hace
adicta pierde simplemente pierde control
completo y y muchos de Los pistoleros
que operan para el cártel si no por
ejemplo les prohíben pueden consumir
cualquier droga menos fentanilo porque
pueden descuidar sus labores y pueden
perder el control de muchas cosas y
bueno Ellos están viendo su seguridad a
la aquí en en México en la zona de
Sinaloa por ejemplo a los carteles los
diferentes grupos criminales que operan
en esa región son grupos que colaboran
entre sí pero hay fricciones en el
centro del país por el particularmente
en la zona de Guanajuato en Zacatecas y
en Michoacán donde opera principalmente
el grupo de El Cártel de Jalisco Nueva
Generación pero a socios del cartes
Sinaloa han intentado ingresar esas
zonas y ha provocado una ola de
violencia terrible como nunca se había
visto en esas zonas y y bueno esto esto
significa de que cada cada grupo
criminal que opera en México está
Está tratando de extender sus dominios y
la guerra por esos territorios continúa
Porque todos ellos saben perfectamente
las ganancias millonarias que dejan la
producción y el tráfico de fentanilo
simplemente aquí en Culiacán en Culiacán
por ejemplo
los narcotraficantes les cuesta producir
un kilo de fentanilo con los precursores
que llegan de manera ilegal desde china
les cuesta producir los dos mil dólares
y una vez que lo producen ellos lo
pueden vender en tres mil dólares pero
cuando lo ponen en Tijuana por ejemplo
lo revenden en siete mil dólares y
cuando lo cruzan a Los Ángeles el el el
el kilo alcanza un valor entre 12 y 15
mil dólares Pero si ese mismo kilo es
puesto en la costa este en Nueva York
por ejemplo el valor puede incrementarse
hasta en 50 mil dólares Entonces es
muchísimo dinero esos grupos tienen el
control territorio Tiene una línea
directa que no se conforman con llevarlo
únicamente a Tijuana o a Los Ángeles
sino que tratan de ponerlo en la costa
este como Nueva York y ahí es donde
están las ganancias Y como te digo esto
está generando una violencia terrible en
donde este gobierno la actual
administración no ha podido controlar
porque por el nivel de corrupción que
existe en México y sinceramente a corto
plazo yo no veo que se vaya a parar y
este esta gana
ncia corrupción desbordada que están
haciendo imposible es frenar la
producción de fentanilo en México y que
usted nos dice dejan una ganancia de
costarles dos mil dólares producir un
kilo de fentanilo y lograrlo vender en
la costa este de Estados Unidos por 50
mil dólares Esto está haciendo que los
carteles se enfoquen y prioricen por
ejemplo la producción y comercialización
de fentanilo por encima de drogas de
hace décadas como la cocaína
bueno No necesariamente la cocaína sigue
siendo una droga de alta demanda lo que
está pasando es que ahora están
mezclando fentanilo con otras drogas
incluyendo la cocaína las metanfetaminas
Entonces esto ha provocado que la la
producción siga de la producción de
fentanilo sigue en aumento y y yo yo la
verdad es que yo me he dado cuenta de
que de que el
lava la alza el consumo de de fentanilo
en cualquiera de sus modalidades en los
Estados Unidos y es algo que no se puede
controlar y es algo que Obviamente que
los carteles de la droga han visto que
les reditúa un alto margen de de
ingresos y y porque al mismo tiempo por
el grado de acción que tiene el
fentanilo y al mezclarlo con drogas como
la cocaína lo vuelven más potente el
efecto para el que quienes lo usan es
más es más potente y y el grado de
acción que genera es más fuerte también
entonces yo no veo como eso vaya a parar
la verdad Michael hablemos de esa
combinación de la que nos está hablando
Miguel Ángel Cuáles son las
consecuencias y los efectos en las
personas en Estados Unidos que están
consumiendo cocaína heroína
metanfetaminas mezcladas con fentanilo
muchas veces sin saberlo
exactamente Y eso es el problema porque
los consumidores aquí en los Estados
Unidos por ejemplo piensan que nada más
están consumiendo
cocaína o metanfetamina y
desconocen que esas drogas tienen 71 Y
eso es lo que ha provocado esta crisis
de las muertes de sobredosis
y en esta crisis de las muertes por
sobredosis tiene algo que ver la
pandemia que también hubo un repunte del
consumo durante y después de esta
exactamente durante la pandemia de covid
aquí en los Estados Unidos se consumió
más droga especialmente femenino cuando
la gente estaba encerrados en las casas
por mucho tiempo
falleció familiares Entonces eso provocó
y aumentó en uso de pergamino y otras
drogas Miguel Ángel y estos carteles
sobre todo Sinaloa y el cartel Jalisco
Nueva Generación están produciendo
fentanilo para otros países o por ahora
en el mundo el mayor consumidor sigue
siendo Estados Unidos
bueno Obviamente que el mayor consumidor
sigue siendo Estados Unidos pero también
Ellos están Ellos están en una constante
búsqueda de por otros mercados otros
territorios y hasta la información que
nos han dado es que ellos envían
fentanilo a Australia al Reino Unido a
Francia y
están tratando de extenderse Por qué Por
qué el interés que tienen los carteles
en mercados como el europeo por ejemplo
es porque las drogas sintéticas las
ofertan a precios mucho más altos a
veces hasta el triple de lo que las
ofertan en Estados Unidos y si los
mercados están creciendo y y están
tomando De pronto es ese rumbo el la la
zona de occidente pero sin duda hoy por
hoy Estados Unidos sigue siendo el
principal consumidor de drogas en el
mundo y particularmente fentanilo sigue
al alza
ante esta expansión del fentanilo en el
mundo Michael Le quiero preguntar si las
autoridades de Estados Unidos están
haciendo alianzas para combatir el
tráfico de este opiáceo
totalmente porque nosotros Ah bueno la
vía tiene oficinas por todo el mundo yo
fui el director de operativos
internacionales Entonces tenemos
oficinas en Europa por todo el mundo
incluyendo China y estamos trabajando
con estos países para tratar de frenar
este crisis Entonces el cartel de
Sinaloa tengo que decir que ahora está
trabajando en seis de los siete
continentes del mundo no trabajan en
antártica porque los pingüinos no tienen
dinero pero la magnitud
y El poder del Cartel De Sinaloa Yo creo
que es el más poderoso
cartel que ha existido en el mundo mucho
más poderoso que el Cartel de Medellín
bajo de Pablo Escobar porque Pablo
Escobar nada más manejaba cocaína ahora
los carteles mexicanos platican todo
tipo de drogas y precisamente en este
tráfico de múltiples drogas Cuál es el
papel del fentanilo en comparación por
ejemplo de la cocaína y la heroína Y qué
se espera en unos años si el consumo
crece en otras partes del mundo como ha
crecido en Estados Unidos Michael
bueno eso va a casa una crisis así
mundial yo creo que ya nos los vínculos
del carteles Sinaloa principalmente con
muchos países traficantes como dice
Miguel en Australia y en Europa y otros
países entonces Esto va a continuar en
la cosa que si México
con López Obrador que dice que no están
produciendo también china dice que no
tiene problemas que ellos no están
causando ninguna problema con los
precursores con el fentanilo Entonces
esto yo creo que sí se va a convertir a
un crisis mundial y una crisis mundial
que sería aún peor que la que provocan
otras drogas otras drogas precisamente
por la letalidad del fentanilo lo barato
que es y lo fácil que es transportarla
en comparación de de otras drogas
ilegales Miguel Ángel quiero ahora ir
con usted Cuál es la conclusión que
usted tiene tanto del repunte de
producción como el repunte de consumo de
fentanilo y hacia adelante qué cree
usted que pueda pasar con estos opiáceos
bueno es algo que es un tema de salud
pública que yo veo difícil que se tenga
y yo siento que los cárteles de la droga
cada vez buscan no solamente buscan
nuevos mercados sino también nuevos
productos en este caso nuevas drogas a
sintéticas para eventualmente ofertarlas
y traficarlas a diferentes a partes del
mundo teniendo como mercado principal
obviamente Estados Unidos no veo que
esto vaya a detener ni a corto ni
mediano plazo y yo siento de que aquí es
una cuestión de que ambos países en este
caso Estados Unidos y México busquen una
estrategia bilateral que que pueda por
lo menos de tener el crecimiento
de en el consumo de droga en Estados
Unidos evitar que con educación con
otras alternativas de carácter Social
para la gente para que no caiga en este
tipo de adicciones porque una vez que el
fentanilo atrapa a un usuario ya no lo
suelta tan fácilmente y es muy
complicado Eso provoca una
descomposición social y si a esto lo
vemos No únicamente en un solo país como
Estados Unidos pero que eventualmente ya
el fentanilo se empieza a utilizar
también en México donde yo me he
enterado de personas mujeres
principalmente que lo utilizan porque se
les informa de que Ah con esta droga tú
puedes bajar de peso y lo empiezan a
usar en un afán de peso que no les
genera ningún tipo de no les da hambre
Entonces esto se puede extender a otras
partes y bueno es imposible para mí
determinar que puede pasar al final no
sé en diez veinte años lo que sí creo Es
que puede se avecina una crisis mundial
de por uso de drogas como fentanilo y
por ello Es que desde ya se utiliza la
palabra epidemia para referirse a la
crisis que está generando el fentanilo
muy brevemente Michael Cuál es su
conclusión
Bueno mi conclusión es que nosotros
necesitamos de mejorar las relaciones
con México
estas organizaciones en los carteles de
de México son
transnacional entonces necesitamos
colaboración un intercambio de
información inteligencia muy amplia y
hasta el momento esto no está sucediendo
con México y los Estados Unidos y los
únicos que van a ganar
van a ser los carteles Gracias Michael
vigilex jefe de operaciones
internacionales de la DEA y Miguel Ángel
Vega periodista de investigación y autor
de El flixter por estar con nosotros en
este debate tan interesante a ustedes
también nuestra audiencia Gracias por
sintonizarnos y les digo gracias En
nombre del equipo técnico la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Jennifer
Guevara y la de los invitados con Tania
Herrera sigan con nosotros en Franz 24
[Música]